[Musica]
ciao a tutti benvenuti sanità stories
oggi trucco di halloween
oggi andrò a trasformarmi in un vampiro
quindi andrò a truccarmi trasformano in
un vampiro in più o qualche accessorio
ad esempio lenti a contatto nuovamente
l'altra volta mi è piaciuto un sacco
quando ho visto la trasformata con le
lenti a contatto pro 9 dic ancora di che
colore sono vediamo se riuscite a
indovinare e poi metterò anche i pezzi
da buon tiro
non vedo l'ora di vedere come si sa come
sempre vi dico io non sono una
truccatrice non sono bravo a truccarmi
però cerco di arrangiarmi insomma quindi
questo non è proprio un tutorial è più
un esperimento una trasformazione da
normale autobus voi poi potrete dirmi se
vi è piaciuto l'effetto finale il trucco
finale o se non vi è piaciuto ho scelto
il bambino perché in genere scelgo
sempre vampiro per halloween perché ho
la pelle molto chiara ai capelli scuri e
appunto i bambini e gli occhi chiari e
in genere i bambini sono così ed è anche
molto semplice travestirsi da capire
perché non hai bisogno di un tocco super
elaborato e mi sono sempre
il ct non vivi da piccola io adoro il
buon piede odore che come con i vampiri
dracula di bram stoker intervista col
vampiro bellissimo io dormo mai vissuto
light tipo l'unica al mondo non averlo
mai visto
vabbè comunque allora iniziamo subito
mettetevi comodi tè caldo cioccolato
patatine e pop corn e iniziamo a tra
l'altro che crei durante questo video e
ora l'altra volta che fatto la
trasformazione alziati con usando i
trucchi che usano gli atleti che mi
avete detto che il fondo sia interno
troppo scuro io ti ho detto appunto che
competenza nel mondo molto quindi non
andrò a riutilizzare fondotinta ho messo
la crema idratante e fate votare del
ciprian this nubile e indistruttibile
bianca praticamente vediamo se miss
chiarissima l'ora non metto punto il
fondotinta promette un po di correttore
perché come vi avevo detto su instagram
quando la piccola avevo tantissimi
brufoli soprattutto infront per un
piccolo pensavo che a 18 anni
una volta che avesse compiuto
diciott'anni in i brufoli serio per un
magicamente spariti tutti quanti perché
pensavo versi a 18 anni sarò bande non è
possibile che avrò ancora i brufoli bay
purtroppo ci sono ancora non sono più
come prima fortunatamente
primario veramente terribile però
qualcuno sia ancora allora ditemi un po
voi da cosa vi toccherete o vestirete a
darwin sono super curiosa scrivete di
tutto nei commenti e perché avete scelto
quel costume o trucco se vi tocca più
basse e semi truccati e basta o se avete
anche il costume di temi tutto allora
per le sopracciglia uso questo che è un
ale monder bravo ed amiche lo uso però
non lo so tutti i giorni perché allora
mi piace un sacco l'effetto che fa lo
vedrete perché essendo in gel le finanze
un po più su insomma al poi modellare
bene però quando vai a toglierlo e
terribile perché va beh a parte che tipo
water brooks supermotard brutto quindi
io anche se lo tolgo con lo struccante
bifasico per il trucco molto il gruppo
poi finisce sempre che mi toglie un
sacco di sopracciglia e a lungo andare
non va bene se così tutti i giorni così
specialmente sopracciglio quindi lo uso
solo ogni tanto
ok ragazze pato le sopracciglia le pare
leggermente più grosse per fare gli
occhi 0
la famosa tecnica già principiante o
manzo il famoso trucchetto in cui si usa
lo scotch qua allora io uso lo scotch
questo cuoche il biadesivo perché è che
un pochino meno appiccicoso rispetto
allo scorso nel male se non potete poi
tirarvi la palpebra e conservare o
quello di carta a quello biadesivo
quindi lo metto conti è troppo lungo
eccolo qua questo è un bellissimo
argento
e far risaltare molto gli occhi
soprattutto quelli tendente al verde e
poi questa è una spesa che è molto
leggero l'effetto come potete vedere
quindi ora vado a mettere in crisi più
scuro per creare un po una sfumatura mi
piace un sacco questo ombretto argentato
ho provato tempo fa anche degli ombretti
dorati ma mi spendiamo ancore degli
occhi quindi suppongo che gli ombretti
dorati faceva risaltare di più di occhi
scuri o nocciola invece per gli
argentati più gli occhi chi è allora me
sinceramente piace questi vorrei
lasciarlo un po naturali per i miei
questi però siccome hanno quindi
aggiungiamo un po di colore allora
aggiungo un ombretto viola metallizzato
che ho aggiunto un pochino i viola scuro
non so se si crede per farli saltare un
pochino di più chi è appena realizzata
una cosa io ho scelto come film e in
base al mio colore degli occhi senza
pensare che poi con le lenti andrò a
cambiare il colore degli occhi
vediamo se si stia per lo step poco
eyeliner poco perché il genere faccio
casino con lei
misti tutto storto eyeliner ora ti amo
via lo scorso mese un sito gay pensavo
peggio
dopo ben ve l'ho detto non sono proprio
molto esperta
ok ecco fatto allora ora vado a fare un
pochino di contouring sporcano di
scuriscano troppo però voglio fare
appunto il controllo in supermarcato
stile tutto bank io quando faccio un po
scappata vedremo se si riesca a un po
più dal basso così che non so se sembra
che ha fatto che scavato forse quesito
quale avete un pochino meglio che va beh
è halloween va bene già questo correre
non piace tantissimo
allora allora ho preso questo rossetto
che
qui è questo un oscuro un viola boffa
bellissimo questo rossa è proprio un
grosso papiro della tinta rossa e volevo
creare degli effetti di sangue o anche
del sangue finto quindi magari prima
credo degli effetti e poi aggiungo un po
di sole uscito invece devo confessare a
questo aperta su cosa non ha neanche un
coperchio l'ho comprato da tiger niente
voluto proprio tra l'altro di temi e ad
halloween andrete in giro fare dolcetto
o scherzetto o siete troppo grandi per
farlo con volete fare di tempo che è
subito bene comunque essere così la
consistenza di un rossetto si piazza
solo sulle palpebre mai notata
incredibile tocca a te scuse che ammette
solo io non amo a piro ciao a tt
trucchiamo da zucca la zucca
ok direi che è ora siamo molto più un
effetto halloween come effetto un
compito vorrei aggiungere il rosso da
qualche parte ma non saprei dove potrei
provare a fare un pezzo dei laender
rosso come di fare un casino ma
proviamoci lo stesso mi fosse un'idea
sotto l'occhio di un effetto nostro
sotto l'occhio allora abbiamo usato
questo posso provocare un tacchino di
sangue finto vediamo che effetto opposto
perché non colli dappertutto è un po più
realistico però mi ricordo che adesso
siamo conflitto si asciuga e fano
costicine un po vedete molto più
realista
adesso sembra finita successo e sangue
ok allora direi che la parte trucco più
o meno non l'abbiamo chiusa ora ci sono
un paio di cose prima delle lenti a
contatto che saranno la cosa più
difficile quindi lo fai per ultimo
allora abbiamo quante i denti da vampiro
perché ovviamente come potevano mancare
il 20 del mattino allora queste le
ordinate su amazon
interessano dimetto il link in
descrizione ed erano questo che i voti
positivi
wow sempre 9 riguardate senza per carini
allora vado primo antonina mani delle
pillole strada dentro con della
polverina per scrivono ad attaccare i
denti appunto ok ragazzi dopo tipo
un'ora sono riuscita a metterli eccoli
qua sono molto realistici però sono un
po un casino attaccare perché ci hanno
una polverina quindi aspettarci minuti
così a bocca aperta
e questi staccavano insomma spero che
ora non si stacchino molto belli anche
se parlo in modo mi mostrano tre aree in
più mi si sono macchiati detti di
rossetto rosso però almeno sempre
sempre ok siamo arrivati all ultimo
aspetto devo mettere le lenti poi metto
il costume perché ho comprato una cosa
bellissima poi abbiamo finito la
trasformazione minuto non mostra mese
con presidenti allora ecco qua le lenti
a quanto 8 speriamo che questa sia più
semplice metterle perché sapete che
un'altra volta e stop
però non voglio nemmeno di vedermi con
questi occhi allora non vorrei posso
vedere vediamo se di scommettere senza
prive del colore
no possibile troviamo astra astra
parlare così sotto identificanti allora
spero che passa un bell'effetto
vado a fare le mani o le mani pulite il
cane e papà che mi assisterà che sta
aprendo la mente siano più primitivi
serie hunting cosa vada meglio non sia
scritto sei destra sinistra
[Musica]
non mi ricordo neanche come ho fatto
l'altra volta utili quel momento sul
lato mi ha aperto l'occhio così non ci
sono le soluzioni
no no non so come fanno quelli che
usavano i denti tutti i giorni è una
tortura
[Musica]
comunque questa sono veramente una scena
horror ed infatti la sera di halloween
io che mi filone dita negli occhi col
sangue alla bocca
allora lo ripeto allora voi portatori di
20 datemi qualche consiglio si prova
tenerla più al centro invece che sul
lago
[Musica]
se periodo
tutto sul lato ci vediamo quasi che
paura ma ora ho ancora non si è
posizionato bello perché vedo tutto il
rostro all'auto ma forse è troppo è
troppo stretto pupilla oh mio dio io
sembro un tiro o no vabbè
inquietantissimo sì peccato che all'atto
vedo tutto rosso cioè è come se certe
della pufin asia abbastanza grande e
quindi sono da un lato credo rosso il
nuovo perno che figata incomodo lettera
plaudente sono un mezzo macchina adesso
come si è
dopo loretta co prima vado a mettere
l'altra lente che la banca difficile
scatti veramente corro stories in italia
unita arrosto poi con un occhio uno
diverso dall'anno è ancora che strano
viavai entrambi gli occhi
comunque disputato un buon meglio
doveste 20 non sono fatte molto bene
tutto rosso non c'è neanche un po di
effetto però almeno sono chiare ma forse
perché voglio cucchiaiate di studi o
meglio il colore non so se con gli occhi
scuri forse rimane più scuro e dunque
proviamo mentre è caduto anche l'altro
daremo così
[Musica]
oggi stress
io mi faccio proprio sono veramente
stanotte bisogno così è un rettore pensi
parecchio ma ora non mi trovi più bella
come vita come sei mesi il più bello la
strizza faccio paura ma sono tipo sarà
di sky e gli scali macchiata c'è questo
chino questi sono fantastici lo so che
sicuramente visto lo spaventato è che
non è finita qua perché dobbiamo va bene
mettere i denti poi del gusto
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi allora questo è il mio look
completo o il mantello rosso poi una
donna e il cappuccio bellissimo perché è
super lungo e fatico cappuccetto rosso
fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate del look
completo della bandiera sapere voi cosa
vi vestirete dal il seno in bella ex
costruito sono nate vedere altre
trasformazioni io mi diverto un sacco a
trasformarmi e ora vi lascio qua 4
candeline su cui potete cliccare per
vedere se volete vedere la mia
trasformazione
se volete vedere i miei video divertenti
che di challenger click
quello che preferite e buona visione